think a little bit but you know the
founders talked about in the content in
the Declaration of Independence their
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness I mean we're not entitled to
happiness which is after all a bit vague
but we're entitled to pursue it and we
have a right to life and liberty and the
assumption is that if we have life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
right then we make decisions and we kind
of have to live by a lot of these
decisions now you say well what happens
if somebody runs into all sorts of
trouble are they just completely out of
the picture well you know we have
charity the founders always believed
that charity for worthy people churches
of course historically have played a big
role in this because churches can do a
lot of one-on-one training and after all
it's Paul in the Bible in Thessalonians
it says if any would not work neither
should he eat you know the idea is that
we ought to have productive people at
the same time they're their provisions
for charity and we see this with Jesus
with Paul and we thought I touched on
Grover Cleveland in the 1800s when we
had that business with the farmers in
Texas who had a poor crop one year and
so Congress that they had their
congressman came in and said help me get
a subsidy for my farmers because they
had a bad crop because of bad climate
and so he says if you'll vote for my sub
see you know we'll get into this that
what we call pork barrel politics
although for your tariff and this kind
of thing and so we ended up getting
Congress passing a ten-thousand-dollar
subsidy it was primarily proceeds for
the farmers but ten thousand dollars for
that district in Texas and so Grover
Cleveland has this bill before him and
everybody says don't you want them to
help the poor and it was a bad climate
it was beyond their control let's help
the poor any vetoed
and you know you think well that isn't
very astute politically but Cleveland
came in there and in the 1880s and he
said hey a hundred years ago our
founders not only wrote a declaration of
independence but they gave us
Constitution it didn't have anything in
there about federal funding for groups
copy for voter blocks for goodness sakes
and he said I'm vetoing it because
nobody can show me anywhere in the
Constitution where this fits so he
vetoed it and then he said however when
people are in need it is the job of
Americans who have a little extra to try
to help and he said I'd like to help
with these farmers and he made a
contribution he didn't really make it
public he said I'm making one but the
trouble is this is not a game of look at
me and look how much on getting private
charity ought to be have a certain
privacy but I just want you to know that
I'm giving something to help these
farmers and I hope others well too
because I believe that they were caught
with a bad climate they didn't get a
crop in and that to me is worthy of it
some charitable help well it turns out
other newspapers picked up the cause and
whereas the federal bill that Cleveland
vetoed was for ten thousand dollars we
had in federal aid or we had in private
charity a hundred thousand that came in
and Cleveland ended up saying this is
the way Americans solve problems it
separates Americans from other people
but we believe it's a rather biblical
way to do it and it's a very sensible
regardless it's a very economically
sensible way to handle charity